el parlamento europeo trata de pasar
página tras el supuesto escándalo de
corrupción que ha afectado a esta
institución de momento ya tiene
substituto para Eva Kylie la ex
vicepresidenta de la eurocámara que se
encuentra en prisión por haber recibido
supuestamente cuantiosas sumas de dinero
por parte de Qatar el nuevo
vicepresidente es también el
eurodiputado socialista luxemburgués
Mark Angel la trama de corrupción ha
afectado gravemente a las instituciones
que han vivido esta trama como un
auténtico shock mientras la
investigación sigue su curso Antonio
panzeri el supuesto cabecilla de esta
trama de corrupción ha aceptado
participar en un nuevo estatus de
arrepentido en una opción que se
contempla a la legislación belga en que
a cambio de ofrecer detalles
sustanciales de la investigación y
también participar en ella se le podrá
rebajar la condena tendrá que pagar una
multa y tendrá que pagar todo el dinero
ha recibido ilegalmente según la prensa
belga Antonio panzeri ya ha empezado a
hablar y apunta a otro eurodiputados
socialista el Marc tarabela que
supuestamente también recibió más de
100.000 euros por parte de Qatar
precisamente la eurocámara esta semana
ya ha empezado el proceso para retirar
la inmunidad a Mark tarabela a petición
de la justicia belga